open up God want for a hectare dollar  taco you got ten seconds to get off us  to just take a step back and take a look  you ain't gonna believe this  got the wrong house lest something  acquire your services get wrong fellas  get my godson back from my ex-husband  Carlos can't Rob's parents lab has a  trust and matures me of 18 I also do  everything to get it why didn't you just  kill me in the first place  giant halo man is a damn smashing  the hell happened  it took the kid sorry boss cries you're  sorry I guess that's all that matters  let me tell you how that's gonna end  I'll send some really awful fishers  message what I guess if you do the math  five four assassins can't drop three  mouth-breathing retards in a [ __ ]  just get my boy back  no indeed Hale No